[Musik]
gaza stadt einen monat später
der schweizer pierre krähenbühl soll es
richten er ist generalkommissar der
unruhe und somit schutzherr der
vereinten nationen über fünf millionen
palästinensische flüchtlinge
sie bringen hoffnung leute wenden sich
an l'or zu und sagen gebt uns hoffnung
weil weder kann man diesen ort verlassen
noch kann man einfach jedes mal den
krieg überleben
es waren viele tote und verletzte und
jetzt muss irgendwie eine
zukunftsperspektive geben und unrat
kante geben
warum man nicht aufgeben darf ein andere
verzweifeln und wie man den
verzweifelten mut macht davon handelt
dieser film
[Musik]
nur selten ist pierre krähenbühl in
seiner wohnung in ost jerusalem
alles ist bescheiden er hastet vom
konferenz zu konferenz gespräche mit
geldgebern mit politikern informieren
blockieren und die familie zu hause in
der schweiz dass dieser mann über ein
budget von mehr als einer milliarde
dollar gebietet und über 35.000
angestellte verfügt würde man kaum
vermuten nur selten bleiben die momente
das erlebte zu verarbeiten
vielleicht viel elend gesehen
persönlich sitzt das sehr tiefe wenn ich
während des krieges auch wieder ende
juli das spital besuchte in gaza das
schifa spital und dort sah wie viele
kinder verletzt in den betten und den
korridors lagen und die augen die blicke
der eltern dann mit denen ich mich
natürlich zutiefst identifizieren kann
weil ich einfach auch mal eine serie
habe und mir gut vorstellen kann was es
heißt wenn man den eindruck hat als
eltern man konnte seine eigenen kinder
nicht schützen in diesem krieg das ist
ja das ist hart und ich glaube auch ist
es sehr wichtig dass man sich an solche
sachen nie gewöhnt gewöhnung ist
vielleicht der grösste feind die gefahr
krieg und gewalt als gegeben hinzunehmen
ist groß bald ein jahrhundert dauert der
konflikt im heiligen land zwischen
israeli und palästinensern ein ende ist
nicht absehbar
doch die öffentlichkeit ist überdrüssig
des ewigen streit verdrängten und will
nichts hören
pierre krähenbühl möchte dass die welt
wieder zuhört und hinschaut
es geht nach gaza für die fahrt von
jerusalem bis zur grenze brauchen wir
wenig mehr als eine stunde
und doch sie führt uns in eine andere
welt
pierre krähenbühl will dass die unruhe
schulen wieder geöffnet werden
er will normalität schaffen aber was ist
schon normalität an einem ort wie gaza
die tatsache dass kinder jetzt
beauftragt in gaza
ohne israel getroffen zu haben
und dass sie von israelis nur die
drohnen und die angriffe und die angst
kennen
das ist etwas was für die zukunft der
region ganz besonders problematisch ist
[Musik]
gaza eine riesige mauer und gibt ein
gebiet kaum größer als genf pierre
krähenbühl es heimatkanton 1,8 millionen
menschen sind darin eingesperrt gaza
wird häufig als freiluftgefängnis
bezeichnet
junge soldaten
wohin ich eigentlich wollte sagt ich
wusste nicht dass man doch woran das
liegen kann als nach gaza das ist es
wohl so teil dieses etwas merkwürdigen
ganze umfeld es bestimmte ich muss hier
aussteigen nur der un-diplomat darf mit
dem wagen über die grenze
am kontrollpunkt ist dann auch schluss
mit film wir sind in einer
sicherheitszone
auf palästinensischer seite schalten wir
die kamera wieder ein dia krähenbühl
steigt in ein gepanzertes fahrzeug um
aus sicherheitsgründen müssen wir
unseren transport selbst organisieren
doch schon nach wenigen hundert metern
verlieren wir den anschluss gleich beim
checkpoint der palästinensischen
behörden bleiben wir stecken
die papiere sind nicht vollständig
ok
erstens passwort
während unser lokaler mitarbeiter beim
innenministerium die papiere besorgt
heißt es für mich abwarten
mit gut drei stunden verspätung geht es
endlich weiter auf dem weg nach gaza
stadt fahren wir durch gerard der
außenbezirk wurde flächendeckend an bord
er liegt nahe der grenze mauer von hier
haben die palästinenser zahlreiche
tunnel gegraben nicht für den schmuggel
sondern um israel anzugreifen
wie die armee sagt die vergeltung ist
vernichtend
doch auf den ruinen wien schon wieder
trotzig die fahnen der hamas
ziel der israelischen angriffe waren
auch zahlreiche moscheen
sie sollen so die begründung der hamas
als waffenlager gedient haben
die moschee war gleichzeitig eine
koranschule mit einer großen bibliothek
der muezzin kommt auf uns zu als er
bemerkt dass wir deutsch sprechen
er selbst hat vor 25 jahren in
deutschland gelebt gibt es nur als teure
viel von diesem es gibt geburt oder 700
koran als gebot
[Musik]
mitten in gaza stadt sind die spuren des
50 tage dauernden krieges weit weniger
deutlich zu spüren
hier liegt das hauptquartier des uno
flüchtlingshilfswerks gesichert wie eine
festung
pierre krähenbühl trifft eine gruppe von
bauingenieuren und sozialarbeiterinnen
sie mussten die letzten wochen hart
arbeiten dabei liegt das meiste noch vor
ihm
der chef ist stolz auf seine leute
er hat meinen größten respekt für all
die arbeit die er geleistet hat sie ist
ganz entscheidende dieser phase nach dem
schrecklichen konflikt den ihr durch
gemacht habt sie sind an der front bei
den vertriebenen ihre häuser verloren
haben
sie berechnen das ausmaß der schäden
die zahlen die sie zusammenstellen gehen
an die internationale gemeinschaft und
entscheiden darüber wie viel geld für
den wiederaufbau nach gaza fließt wenn
wir in die hauptstädte gehen und darüber
berichten was hier geschehen ist machen
wir es den politikern schwere ihre
aufmerksamkeit anderen krisen zuzuwenden
unsere rolle ist es ihre ganze
aufmerksamkeit auf gaza zu erlangen
denn die internationale gemeinschaft ist
auch verantwortlich für das was hier
passiert ist weil sie die leute nicht
genug geschützt hat und weil das ausmaß
der zerstörung so riesig ist
krähenbühl ist beunruhigt er weiß wenn
jetzt die internationale gemeinschaft
nicht massiv druck auf israel und die
hamas ausübt passiert gar nichts
bisher kommt kaum baumaterial für den
wiederaufbau nach gaza hinein da die
kriegsparteien einander keine
zugeständnisse machen
denkt der denkt er in der gegend
bei den hörnern wenn das so weiter geht
dann sind wir in zwei monaten immer noch
da kommt kein baumaterial
und die leute sitzen in die hand
das so kurz vor dem winter kann ich mir
eigentlich persönlich gar nicht
vorstellen da will ich nicht mitspielen
da will ich auch das wurde gesagt dass
leute jetzt konkret aktivitäten von uns
sehen konkrete änderung arbeitet
langfristige wiederaufbau das hängt von
politischen oder da muss ganz klar sein
man darf nicht mit der zukunft dieser
menschen spiel während pierre krähenbühl
zu einem geschlossenen meeting weiter
heilt schaue ich mich auf dem gelände um
die uhr kümmert sich um die ausbildung
der palästinenser und so findet sich
auch eine schule auf dem gelände
eigentlich ein college für ältere
schüler
doch die müssen jetzt den platz mit
kindern teilen deren schulen zerbombt
wurden oder flüchtlingen als unterkunft
dienen
[Musik]
unterricht gibt es so kurz nach dem
krieg nicht nicht einmal über die
schrecken der letzten wochen sprechen
die betreuer mit den kindern drei kriege
haben die mädchen in ihrem kurzen leben
erlitten
sie sollen erst einmal wieder erfahren
dass das leben nicht nur aus tod und
angst besteht
es kann auch freude machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das nächste meeting zeigt mir wie stark
sich pia krähenbühl engagiert das sind
die mitarbeiter umarmen hat guten grund
dreimal war während des krieges in gaza
das rechnen sie ihm hoch an
er ist nicht nur chef er ist auch freund
aber wo bleibt die neutralität wird er
nicht selbst partei ich versuche sehr
diese wichtigen neutralität zu bewahren
obgleich wie ich immer sage ich bin
nicht neutral geboren habe ich bin hier
um mich konzentriert zu engagieren für
die würde und die lage der flüchtlinge
der palästinensischen flüchtlinge
für die mitarbeiter steht eine offene
fragerunde an jeder kann vortragen was
ihm am herzen liegt
oft haben die palästinenser das gefühl
als menschen zweiter klasse behandelt zu
werden und so falsch ist der eindruck
nicht die öffentlichkeit hat sich an die
zahllosen toten unter den palästinensern
gewöhnt und nimmt sie längst
schulterzuckend hin ja krähenbühl will
aufrütteln
das haben wir nie akzeptiert und werden
wir nie akzeptieren
die welt muss wissen palästinenser sind
nicht einfach statistik das leiden hier
ist überall auf der welt die familien
die unter den kämpfen leiden haben die
gleichen hoffnungen erwartungen und
pläne fürs leben wie sonstwo deswegen
werden wir nie akzeptieren dass ihre
schicksale einfach auf zahlen reduziert
werden
[Musik]
auch unruhe schulen waren kampfzone das
obwohl viele vertriebene hier zuflucht
suchten
wo sollten sie auch hin das kriegsgebiet
verlassen konnten sie nicht unter dem
schutz der unruhe glaubten sie sich
sicher doch dem war nicht so
in diesem fall galt der angriff einer
polizeistation
dabei wurde die daneben liegende schule
auch getroffen
die israelische armee ist in der lage
mit höchster präzision ziele zu treffen
trotzdem hat sie in sieben fällen
unwahre schule getroffen
wir haben gerade um sie zu schützen
die israelische armee zb 17 mal daran
erinnert wo unsere schule ist 33 mal
haben wir die raphaelschule notifiziert
die hintere kam es zu diesen
zwischenfällen
das hat uns natürlich dazu brachte erst
mal diese zwischenfälle zu verurteilen
öffentlich auch in den zwei fällen rafah
barriere ist direkt dafür verantwortlich
zu machen und für untersuchungen
so verlangen der beschuss von zivilen
einrichtungen verstößt gegen das
völkerrecht es ist ein kriegsverbrechen
allerdings gab es den vorwurf dass
waffen in den schulen versteckt waren
doch auch das lässt pierre krähenbühl
nicht gelten denn er war selbst
schockiert und hatte die funde sofort
öffentlich gemacht drei mal haben wir
während unserer eigenen
speck ziehen
waffen gefunden die würden von gruppen
hier in gaza dort gelagert das haben wir
öffentlich verurteilt wir haben selber
an die öffentlichkeit gebracht weil wir
eben glaubten dass es in dem fall nur
transparenz sich rechtfertigen kann
und ich glaube das ist auch wichtig die
welt weiß davon beim rohr das selber
mitgeteilt hat und verurteilte bis heute
dienen über 18 und schulen als
flüchtlingslager an unterricht ist nicht
zu denken
solange es keine anderen unterkünfte
gibt die zerstörung der schulen ist fast
das kleinere problem
32.000 menschen wohnen noch in den
schulhäusern sie können nicht einfach
wieder rausgeworfen werden
der uno chef will aus erster hand wissen
wie es den vertriebenen ergangen ist
zwei frauen die mit ihren familien aus
dem stadtteil china geflohen sind
berichten ihm ein mitarbeiter dolmetscht
sie mussten ganz unverhofft flüchten nun
konnten nichts mitnehmen
mit der erzählung werden sie von ihren
gefühlen überwältigt alle kinder auf der
welt sind glücklich nur unsere kinder
nicht wo immer wir um hilfe nachfragen
werden wir wie bettler behandelt
man nimmt uns unseren stolz weg wir
werden gedemütigt selbst wie ein kleines
stückchen brot müssen wir uns anstellen
dass man sprachlos wenn sie mit so viel
konfrontiert werden nein ich sprachlos
man muss immer gut zu hören weil man
versteht die lage nur insofern wenn man
dem anderen zuhört und ich glaube hier
wird viel mitgeteilt und wenn man das so
richtig anhört dann weiß man dass
niemand auf dieser erde verdient hat so
was mit zu erleben und das haben sie
jetzt gerade mitgeteilt sie sind schon
palästinensische flüchtlinge und jetzt
sind sie noch mal vertrieben
die lebensbedingungen für die
vertriebenen sind beengt vier familien
teilen sich ein klassenzimmer allein die
familie in tais zählt elf personen
privatsphäre gibt es nicht zumeist sind
nur frauen und kinder hier die männer
sind weg so unter den frauen das ist
nichts für sie
[Musik]
dresden teils einer der söhne bildung zu
seinem vater bringen
er lebt in seinem haus oder dem was
davon übrig geblieben ist
das quartier ist arg zerstört der
angriff kam in der nacht ohne vorwarnung
der vater ein paar freunde und der onkel
dem das haus gehört sitzen herum
reparieren können sie nichts wenn sie
haben kein baumaterial
der vater erzählt vom angriff wir saßen
in unseren plötzlich wurde das haus
neben uns bombardieren
da ist auch bei uns das dach eingestürzt
meine kinder wurden verletzt und schrien
und auch ich wurde am fuß verletzt die
trümmer sind auf uns herunter gestürzt
drei kinder meines bruders wurden
getötet die anderen nur verletzt jetzt
lebt der vater hier und hat sich in den
trümmern häuslich eingerichtet in die
unrwa schule wähler nicht zurück glück
im unglück eine granate die ins haus
einschlug ist nicht explodiert die ist
auch im haus gelandet wenn sie
explodiert wäre wären wir alle
umgekommen
vier weitere blindgänger sind hier in
der gegend runtergegangen
wir können gott dankbar sein dass wir
nicht alle tot sind
[Musik]
es war der schlimmste krieg der letzten
jahre den die menschen in gaza erleiden
mussten
dabei das leben kann auch hier beinahe
idyllisch sein
der strand ist vielleicht der letzte
rückzugsort der das elend vergessen
lässt
[Musik]
es tönt absurd aber die zerstörung kann
auch ein gutes haben
sie gibt den konfliktparteien die chance
ihrer feder zu überdenken und neu
anzufangen
gaza könnte ein anderer ort sein
[Musik]
ich muss sagen es tut natürlich der
seele gut wenn man so im mittelmeer
schauen kann man sich ein bisschen
entspannen kann aber die tatsache ist
nun mal dass man kann in diese richtung
schauen man kann eine anrechnung schauen
die zerstörung bleibt
das elend und das leiden bleibt für
pierre krähenbühl kein grund zu
verzweifeln sondern ein ansporn mehr um
für die zukunft dieser menschen zu
kämpfen
[Musik]
wenn ich jetzt hoffnung aufgeben würden
heißt es ungefähr dass ich natürlich
einfach akzeptieren dass gewalt immer
recht hat
und das kann ich nicht akzeptieren das
habe ich in meinem ganzen leben nicht
akzeptiert und ich werde auch heute ich
nicht hier in gaza damit beginnen
vielleicht scheitert pierre krähenbühl
aber hoffnung ist nicht die überzeugung
dass etwas gut ausgeht sondern die
gewissheit dass etwas sinn macht egal
wie es ausgeht
[Musik]